homo
il ya beaucoup de gens qui soit à vision
aération pour défendre des filles en
train de courir en pleurs rempiler green
crier et beaucoup cours puis quelqu'un
qui menace de se suicider nous en tant
qu'adolescent on ne sait pas comment
gérer ça parce qu'on n'en a pas assez
parlé ce professeur a décidé d'enseigner
le violent tôt m voici comment ça se
passe quand un cours vos pieds créée en
france en 2018 pour évaluer si une
relation amoureuse et scène cet outil
comporte un code de couleurs avec des
exemples très précis il est utilisé
presque partout en france et maxime côté
s'en est inspiré faites attention
vigilance dans le kop camp lors d'un
contrôle des sorties à mon maquillage
demandé glide ça va très mal
si l'eau dans le copi maintenant d'un
diffuser les photos intimes de toi on
est très affectés on nous remet ce par
la force des choses c'est peut-être
conscient mais il ya une joie règne
il est donc dans les familles il y en a
certains qui vont l'aborder
je pense que plusieurs ne vont pas le
faire nous les enseignants ont de vos
jeux ça va pas bien sur le court aller
chercher de l'aide si loeb te pousse de
dire de gvt et de ce coup ou deux
frappes le dans un coup si la violence
physique fait partie de l'équation
trois adolescents sur 10 ont déclaré
avoir subi une forme de violence dans
les relations amoureuses au cours des 12
derniers mois
quand aborde les questions de la
violence conjugale est ce que ça suscite
beaucoup de réactions donc et louise
énormément je suis surpris du fait qu'
il ne semble pour être d'un mâle
identifié onze des limites quand l'homme
la baisse des opinions et des projets
déposés pour nîmes et vous offre fini
tout ça est aujourd'hui clairement dit
que je ne suis pas d'accord
beaucoup de personnes disaient aouicha
fâché et j'ai frappé dans un moment
comme si c'était normal mais coeur
personnes lundi
mais non c'est pas normal je sais que
dans ma génération les autres ils
peuvent rire de toi qui disais pourquoi
ton pas
adultes puis ils font croire que t'es
pas fort c'est la violence psychologique
qui est la forme de violence le plus
rapporté par les jeunes souvent vécue
par l'entremise de leur téléphone
cellulaire
attention vigilance tort lorsque l'eau
ce tour mais c'est un droit fondamental
que se garder au petit jardin secret où
ça se produise
c'est dans ta poche que tu fonces il l'a
alors tu l'as toujours avec toi les
possibilités d'abus de le contrôler
ça te suis toujours comment prévenir les
féminicides la solution est peut-être
ici sur les bancs d'école
je trouve que c'est vraiment une
nécessité qui manque dans notre système
de l'éducation peuvent travers l'amour
avant que ça se produise ses drames le
convoi va pages des journaux etc
c'est vraiment en avance je pensais le
monde